hello everyone welcome to the um second
lightning talk session of today my name
is vincent i'll be your host and what
we're going to do is just going to have
six people share their ideas in
convenient short little nuggets
the first person to speak is simona
could you please set up your screen
yes
so i'm simona and i'm a research
scientist at data eq and so this is
about how we move stress from the user
to the model
so we have trained a machine learning
model and we are evaluating it in
experimental conditions so we have a
small carefully collected data set which
is similar to train set and when we
evaluate it we get great performances
and we want to ship it
deployment time things are not the same
data is large and vary it's different
from the training set because of many
situations noise corruption and these
situations are usually called dataset
shift we cannot evaluate because we
don't have labeled data and there is
high risk of low performance so the
question we have at this point is
is this model robust and we would like
to help answer this question proposing
to run stress tests to simulate the
model behavior over a range of scenarios
before deployment
simulating deployment conditions might
be tricky because there are so many
things we could simulate so we need to
ask the user in the loop
in order to use a human expectation
about what are the desired properties of
the model for instance you can think of
nlp tasks like sentiment classification
and when you have a sentence like this
one which is classified positive you
would like that your model will also
classify similar words just change a
similar word as a the same sentence
positive and also same thing for
possible typos so this is the kind of
invariance you would like in your model
similarly when you have visual tasks you
would like your model to behave the same
regardless contrast changes rotations
similar things and if you have
structured data maybe you would like
your model to be invariant to some small
numeric changes and also to be robust to
adversarial perturbations
similarly you might also want to use
expert knowledge about the task attend
about possible data degradation that you
could expect deployed in time for
instance you might know that the ten
percent of missing values for a variable
might occur maybe five percent appliers
maybe ten percent of noisy data where
the specific noise is really task
specific and should be designed with the
expert knowledge
and more generally you might want that
your model being valiant subpopulation
shift like when you have different class
proportions in your data or more
generally when you have different
population proportions for instance you
have much more data coming from
america's than from europe and even much
much less than
from africa but you still might want
your model to perform equally well on
those three segments of your data
so first step in stress center is to
define data changes that reflect the
desired properties of the model and you
can do that as i said including the
expert knowledge in the in the process
but you might also want to leverage all
the great tools that you have out there
about data augmentation packages such as
text attack for nlp tasks augmentation
for visual tasks but there are many more
and adversarial attacks such as art by
ibm and foreign text attack is based on
leverages
transformers embedding to produce
similar words on what you have in your
data
the second step in strasster center is
to apply those changes to the original
test set such that you can produce many
shifted data sets and then you evaluate
your model and these many shifted data
sets and finally you compute robustness
metrics to try to answer the question we
said the beginning is this motherboard
so the next style is about how do we
compute robustness metrics so the first
natural idea is to compute performance
drop so for instance you might have a
basic metric for your classification
accuracy and the r2 score maybe for
regression and you want to compute how
the performance drop when going from the
clean data set to the shifted data set
this will give you a table such as this
one for instance and you could say maybe
that the performance drop below five
percent is good enough to go to deploy
your model
another important metric is the stress
resilience rate this is for sample
perturbations and it measures the
percentage of samples for which the
perturbation does not change the
prediction so it's really a measure of
resilience and it can be computed as a
one minus the percentage of class flip
in case of classification or a similar
metric but but after applying clustering
for regression
and finally for superpolation shift you
might want to compute what's the group
performance for instance in that
classification you compute worst group
accuracy and this is important because
you won't
you won't hide as the standard accuracy
the fact that you might have a lower
performance on some underrepresented um
court of your data
but all these metrics i showed below
before it's they are global but you
might also want to know if there are
specific regions of your feature space
where your model is unstable or not
really robust with respect to the to the
the average for instance if you follow
me on this model here it's a regression
model you might have two clean samples
and the first one you can apply
perturbations on both of them and you
can see compute the prediction and in
this case you will see you have some
mean prediction and also some variance
and in the predicted values and the
variance is much higher for the first
sample for the second sample so we say
that you have a measure of uncertainty
and the first sample is in a region that
is much more uncertain where the model
is much more unstable
so samples with i uncertainty are the
most sensitive to the perturbations and
this is something that is locally
important for the model to know
and this is also a measure of robustness
and doesn't apply to the population
shift
so we are releasing two uh open packages
regarding this one is drift deck which
is about to basically collects a battery
of uh perturbation that you could use
include also increment and stress test
center which is really to run stress
test and compute the robustness metrics
i was showing before so it really goes
um like you first first step we see
before the first you can configure your
test test
sorry stress test like replace word and
typos in this in this image and then you
can
instantiate a stress test generator
which you would use then in a circuit
learn like syntaxes fit transform to
generate your upper
data sets and then you compute the
prediction and finally you can use these
two functions get stress metric and get
critical samples to compute the
robustness metrics we've seen before
finally you could use strass test center
also to
perform some other selection to tell
apart equi-accurate models imagine that
you train two models like this one here
and you compute the accuracy on the test
set and you have very similar accuracy
so you might think that these two models
look the same
but are they
actually when you look closer you guys
could see that
the boundaries of the first model are
much less regular than the second model
and actually the first model is much
more sensitive to adversarial tax than
the second model so the idea is that you
could run stress tests to finally
measure robustness and pick the most
robust model for deployment
so what we've seen so far is that we
might have dataset shift affecting
deployment conditions but we might also
leverage human expectations to guide the
stress that design
and we've seen how we could measure
moderateness and how to leverage this
robustness to finally perform modest
selection before deployment
so if you have any questions i'd be
happy to take them now or also later on
slack or
anywhere and thank you for uh listening
thank you very much um because these are
lightning talks though we will have to
move the questions to another segment
but we can now already start preparing
for the next speaker um in this
particular case if marco could start
sharing his screen please that's great
nice and quick um everyone um please
give a
yeah warm applause to marco and his
lighting talk
[Applause]
thank you thank you all right hello
everybody
let's talk about nbqa
that is quality assurance for jupiter
notebooks
this is a little python package which i
put together just over one year ago
and it allows you to run code quality
tools such as isot flake8 mypi and so on
on jupyter notebooks so today i'll tell
you a bit about why i put this together
how i put this together and then finally
what it can do for you
so this is the story starts in july 2020
which is when the first tacky version
came out
so at the time i was a bit frustrated
that when i was writing python code i
had a huge array of code quality tools
that i could choose from
but if i wanted to use a jupyter
notebook say for documentation or as a
tutorial
then there was very little to choose
from
in particular i really wanted to run my
pie over a jupiter notebook i had
so i figured whatever i'll just
put together a little package to do this
and the first hurdle i encountered were
the jupiter magics which are syntax
which is not ordinarily part of python
and my very clever way of dealing with
that was with regular expressions
yeah unfortunately i didn't know any
better at the time
so i wasn't really expecting anyone to
start using this
until a few months later jirish and
sebastian entered the scene
these were two very talented
contributors who started submitting very
high quality pull requests on github
they really helped to drive the project
forwards and it was a lot of fun to work
with them
in fact here is an actual picture of us
working together
so thanks together thanks to them the
products became a lot more robust a lot
more stable and finally in july of this
year i made the first version 1.0
release
which added support for user-defined
scripts but most importantly it replaced
those weak unreliable and flimsy regular
expressions with a strong robust and
maintainable ast passing
so what's the result of this being who's
using it
if we look around on github we can find
it being used in repositories owned by
google microsoft faculty ai
even the uk government and a bunch of
open source libraries
i've seen some endorsements of it on
twitter from some people who have
recognized and on the python package
index it's ranked within the top three
percent of packages in terms of number
of downloads
so has this made me rich and famous
uh well no
i've not made a any
pennies of profit from it
however that's not an issue because i
have an amazing job at an absolutely
amazing company and if you're interested
in hearing more please do message me at
the conference or just have a look at
gusto.co.uk jobs
right do you want to hear more about the
history of nbqa
yeah i didn't think so so let's move on
to how to actually use it and what it
can do for you
so installation is just pip install nbqa
the dependencies are minimal so it won't
conflict with anything you're already
using
if you want to use it just
you just use it as you would normally
run your tool like i sort just put nbqa
in front of it there's configuration
options for filtering files when running
on a directory
for previewing files as well as for
passing extra flags to your code quality
tools
and you can set this configuration
either either at the command line or in
a pipeprojects.com file
and then finally if like me you love to
use pre-commit you can pick and choose
from one of the many pre-commit hooks
which nbqa exposes for you
so in conclusion we've seen how mbqa can
help you run good quality tools on your
jupyter notebooks
installation is simple just pip install
nbqa
and you can run it in ci and or via
precommit to ensure that your notebooks
will stay of a consistent quality
uh thanks for your attention now please
go out and write a maintainable jupyter
notebook uh that was a really cool
lighting talk i have one thing to add
there
there was a research done where they
downloaded i think 42 million jupiter
notebooks see whether or not if you
download the jupyter notebook from
github if it would run
and i think one of the conclusions was
uh if
depending on what kind of imports it
does about only two percent or something
like that are able to run from github as
uh anyway uh this tool sounds like it
might actually help get the number up
there so thanks for that this looks like
an amazing project we'll definitely
check it out
having said that uh we are now going to
move to the next speaker uh francesco if
you could uh get your screens shut up
please
thank you very much and thank you for
having me here i'm franziska zio
developer advocate at ivan which is a
nice finnish company providing open
source data platforms on top of the
cloud of your choice
this choice of data platforms include
apache kafka that we will talk today
and this kind of talk is about you
getting started with apache kafka and
faker data
in order to understand why you need this
combination
let's assume that at a certain point in
your life you get into pachikafka and
you know
you install it and maintain it yourself
your kafka cluster which is kind of hard
or you use a many solution like ivan
no matter which solution you pick at a
certain point you arrive to a situation
where your kafka cluster is up and
running hooray
and then you ask yourself okay what
should i do now
how can i use kafka
and you know kafka is a data platform
but it's a special kind of data platform
it's a streaming data platform and let
me tell you a secret
kafka as
like a lot of other data platforms
it's
empty by default
and you know kafka is a streaming data
platform so it's not like a database
that you take one static sample of data
and you push it to the database and job
done
in order to understand the beauty of
kafka you need a streaming source of
data a continuous flow of data
and if you like me at the beginning when
i was trying to discover kafka you are
trying stuff by yourself
you probably are in a situation where
you don't have any kind of data
even more any kind of streaming there
on the other side you could be part of a
company
and you ca you are trying the kafka for
that company that could have the perfect
data set the perfect use case streaming
use case that could fit kafka
but because
you know internal policies because you
are trying a new tool a new vendor you
could have
limitations in using that perfect data
set still you have an idea of which
fields you want to test with what is
your message type
so we are here at pidara a conference
about python developers and the beauty
of being a developer is that you can
basically choose your hero
with kafka we can choose a lot of heroes
because there are a lot of
prebuilt libraries that interact with
kafka but in this case of course we will
choose python
and in order to interact with python and
kafka we just need to install the
default kafka python library
once we install the kafka python library
we just need to import the kafka
producer to create an instance of the
kafka producer pointing to one of the
nodes of kafka
and then we can just start sending
messages
in here we are sending a message to a
topic which is like a table in a
database but in kafka
and we are passing a few row bytes
in order to make sure that the message
reaches kafka we just need to flash the
message
all simple and clean
the problem is that i teach you how to
send something to kafka but still you
don't have anything to send to kafka and
here is where faker comes in
faker is a library that you can install
by pip
and then you can start using it
you can import you create an instance
and then faker has pre-build functions
that allows you to for example
create a fake name
i use the name function and it outputs
lucy schindler or something like that
i can use also the address function and
creates a fake address the next time
that i will call the name and the
address function i will probably get a
new name and a new address
but faker doesn't stop here you know as
you may understand i've understood i'm
italian so i like to italianize a lot of
things and you can customize also faker
to speak italian you just need to pass
the local e.t and then next time you
call the name function severino zakanyi
it's a pretty italian sounding name the
address itself is a pretty italian
sounding address probably is not correct
because libya sardo will not be
under palermo which is not under the
bulls and province but you know
it sounds correct enough
even more faker has the ability of
creating always different names
prefixing the function name with unique
on the other side if we want to for
example feed kafka with always the same
sequence of events
we can see faker with a precise number
so the randomizer always follows the
same pattern
and
of course faker doesn't only limit
itself to naming addresses it has a lot
of pre-built providers and you can see
the list of providers in the url above
you can for example generate automotive
data like car plates a lot of automotive
other type of data geographical data
from countries to city to provinces
bank information fake bind transaction
think bank names iban and swift codes
even fake python code if you want
but of course we cannot expect faker to
cover all the possible use cases
you can imagine me really surprised when
i discovered that faker wasn't able to
generate fake pizzas
but luckily we can extend faker
we can extend it
and all we need to do is to import the
base provider
to for example in our case create a list
an array of valid pizza names
and now we can create a class pizza
provider extending the base provider and
within the class a pizza name function
that returns a random choice among the
ones available in our
array
now that we have this extension we can
use this extension to create fake pizza
and we just need to add the pizza
provider to our faker instance and we
can for example generate five random
pieces
now that we have those five random
pieces we can either create more complex
messages that we may want to push to
kafka so for example we can include the
id of the pizza order let's say
the shop name again that we built with
an extension of
the fake instance
phone number just check here i'm using
unique to have always used different
phone numbers a fake address and a list
of pieces that we generated above
if we did everything correctly now we
have
a fake
pizza order that we can feed kafka with
and just check here we have the idea of
the order the shop the name arsenio
pizarro boccaccio the phone number the
address and two pizzas one is diablo
with them and the other is the amazing
diablo with mozzarella onion and the
beautiful banana something that i
wouldn't suggest in
pizza but as i understood it's quite
common in the nordics
i want to leave you with some references
that allow you to start your journey
with kafka the first one is the link to
faker
check it out because it has also good
documentation how you can use it
the second thing is if you want to take
this
example and start building your producer
for kafka check out the blog post that i
wrote some time ago
together with
a repository that you can use it's
written in python that you can use to
start creating fake pizza orders fake
metrics
fake stock values that will feed a kafka
instance the last bit is if you want to
try apache kafka but you don't want to
spend time installing an antenna to
yourself check out ivan dotto the
company that i work for because we offer
that as many service and we offer also a
juicy 300 and one month of free trial
that you can use in order to check all
our services and please let me know what
you think about them
i hope the session was entertaining and
you got something out of it reach out to
me in twitter or in
slack for more questions thank you very
much from francesco
so i didn't know bananas were on pizzas
but uh there you go neither did i until
i joined a company in finland
the world never ceases to amaze me uh
thanks for that talk in the meantime
james if you could get set up uh you are
the next speaker uh james lightler i'm
hoping i'm pronouncing the name
correctly who will be talking about argo
which is a new rule generation and
optimization package
the one thing i got to check though is
james inn
i am
can you see me
uh i can see you and i can see the
iguana so i think we're almost ready to
go
good yeah
go ahead
i'll i'll just give you one more
applause and then you are ready to go
[Applause]
cool yeah so so just a quick and
clarifying point there um it was
originally called argo um but we've
we've now changed it to iguanas for kind
of legal issues but uh yeah um this is
our new package um that we've developed
so firstly just thanks everyone to um
for joining the uh the presentation just
a little intro for myself um my name's
james laidler
and i'm a senior data scientist at
paypal um and yeah i'll be going through
our new package that we've developed
which is um basically around rule
generation and optimization
so firstly just to understand why we
actually developed this package in the
first place
and we need to understand what rules and
rule-based systems are
so a rule is essentially just a set of
conditions which if met trigger a
certain response
and so an example of a rule that we
often
deal with in paypal is one that captures
a particular type of fraudulent
behaviour um
and this rules logic might look
something like this so if the number of
transactions made from a given email
address in the past four hours is
greater than 10 then reject the uh the
transaction so that's for something like
an e-commerce company
um
now a real base system is essentially
one that leverages
um a number of these rules to provide a
certain outcome
so a one that we tend to deal with is um
a rule-based system that might accept
reject and review transactions for an
e-commerce company
so
um as with kind of any approach um
there's usually pros and cons and um
it's no different for rbs's so the first
pro um for an rbs is that the rules are
intuitive and so the outcome um is
usually quite easy to understand because
um the the rules that have triggered to
give the decision you can usually um
have some intuitive kind of
understanding of um the second prone is
that rbs is quite flexible because you
can add or take away rules and to
address new behavior
and the third pro is that rules are
usually built using domain knowledge um
and that domain knowledge might actually
capture behavior that an ml model
um
would have would have missed
um but in terms of the cons
so the first one is actually linked to
the the last pro in the domain
knowledges is usually required and so to
essentially build rules you usually need
some sort of demand knowledge um in the
first place
and the second con
is that generating these rules can often
be challenging and time consuming
especially if you use a data guided
approach and so it can be very time
consuming to kind of
use that data and manually go through
and try and create rules based on
analysis that um that you're doing
manually
um
and the third con is that it's uh
usually very difficult to tweak existing
rules so um quite often you'll have
existing rules that are already um being
used and if you want to
optimize those um
for new data it's very difficult to do
that
and that's really where iguanas comes in
and helps to
streamline the the process of setting up
an rbs so um the first kind of um
pro to iguanas is that it only requires
a historic data set so it's very similar
to the requirements of a
ml model in that respect and it can also
quickly and easily generate um high
performance rules
um and utilizes an api that's very
familiar to most data scientists and
that's the
the skill sk-learn kind of fit transform
methodology
um
it also has a real optimization module
and that allows users to quickly and
easily um tweak the thresholds of
existing rules in a rule set and based
on new label data
iguanas also has a host of other modules
that really to help streamline the the
obvious setup process and i'll quickly
mention those at the end of the
presentation
so just to give a quick overview of how
the rule generator works in iguanas
so in essence it um
takes a trend tree ensemble model and it
iterates through the branches of each
decision tree with within that model and
extracts the high-performing branches
um and
since the branches are just a set of
conditions they're essentially
rules as well so they can be thought
over as rules
and so there's a very simple example on
the right here and we have a shallow
decision tree and it has two reject leaf
nodes
um and so what the rule generator will
do is just extract those branches
and and output those as reject rules so
in this case the rule number one would
be order amount greater than 500
and a new customer
and then the second rule would be order
amount less than 500
and transaction volume is greater than
20 in the last 90 days
so in terms of uh the types of data you
can apply this to um we
have facilities to work on for it to
work on both pandas and spark data
frames
um and we did a little test on um a data
set of a million rows
um and 150 columns and compared that
with scope which is a
package that is used for real generation
and is relatively well known as well and
we found that it was around four times
faster in that case than than scope as
well which is a good result
so in terms of the the rule optimizer um
so this essentially just takes a set of
existing rules and couples that with a
labeled data set and a and an objective
function and then using version
optimization it will optimize the rules
um and optimize their thresholds and
then output uh
an optimized rule set so
the the cool thing with this is that you
can the user can actually specify um an
exact metric for optimization via that
objective function so it's not limited
to a predefined metric such as precision
you can use any kind of uh
optimization function to to optimize the
rules
um and even though we call it a rule
optimizer um it can actually be applied
to
any condition so for example if you have
a set of rules that work together to
give a decision you can actually use the
rule optimizer to optimize the
thresholds of these rules in tandem
um
and when we tested the rule optimizer on
on a data set again and we found
that and to optimize 50 rules on a dead
set of a million records and it took
around 11 seconds um to run and it also
doubled the mean f1 score of the rules
which was a pretty good result as well
so i mentioned earlier on in the the
presentation that there were additional
modules to help with the setup of an rbs
and so firstly
um we've developed a grid search cv
module and that essentially searches for
the best type of parameters to use when
generating or optimizing rules
and this utilizes uh careful stratified
cross-validation to do that um there's
also a correlation reduction module and
that removes correlated rules uh from a
rule set and given a similarity metric
such as jaccard similarity
the greedy filter
module also removes rules that do not
add value to
or potentially degrade the performance
of an rbs
and then finally we've got the real
scorer module and that generator score
for each rule
and these scores can often be used in
the setup of a an rbs
and
so yeah so many modules
in addition to the real generator and
real optimizer that can help with the
setup of
an rbs
so hopefully you'll be asking at this
point where can you get it um
unfortunately it's it's not currently
available
um just because we're in some final
discussions with the the legal team in
terms of open sourcing it but we have
got
the uh the repo sorted on the uh public
side of the paypal and github um so
that's where it'll be and i'll share
this link in the the slack channel for
pi data
um and then obviously once it's
available we'd really appreciate um
everybody's feedback um comments
questions um and uh yeah it'd be really
great to hear from you guys
um and that wraps it up so thanks again
for for joining us that was useful
okay thank you uh that means we can move
on to the next lightning talk speaker
we're going to talk about pragmatic
advice for implementing responsible
machine learning
uh violeta uh could you set up your
screen please
uh thank you so much for for having me
my name is violeta micheva and i'm
joined by my colleague leonor tidaman
and we are from the foundation for best
practices in machine learning
before i tell you about the foundation
let me just say why
we
started it
basically
most of you would agree that if
developed and deployed carelessly
machine learning can result in harmful
and sometimes detrimental consequences
on the other side we see more and more
institutions coming out with their own
principles and guidelines that machine
learning and ai models should abide by
but most of them remain sort of
very abstract and just lofty principles
it's really not clear how can you
practically implement them
and last but not least it's hard to
operationalize responsible machine
learning without the proper
organizational support
so uh being frustrated by all of this
around 10 or 11 months ago
we founded the foundation for best
practices in machine learning
our mission is to champion ethical and
responsible machine learning through
open source best practices and free
public knowledge
all the foundation members are
volunteers
for none of us this is our main
task so we all do this besides our our
jobs and all of us work in the domain of
ai and machine learning in some way or
another for example
in among our
members we have machine learning
engineers and data scientists
statisticians and researchers but also
legal and compliance professionals ai
addresses etc
so the foundation is a non-for-profit
organization
we create open source best practices and
we are licensed under the creative
commons attribution license
and just to give you a sneak peek of
what the
best practices are
so we've developed so far the so-called
technical best practices and
organizational best practices
you can think of them as two documents
where the technical best practices is
focused on a single product namely a
machine learning model
and the organizational best practices is
focused or its scope is the whole
organization
and the technical best practices are
mediated through life cycle management
they are embedded in the machine
learning development cycle and
organizational best practices are
mediated through policies
and
both of them cover the same subjects
these are areas within
the domain of machine learning which we
as an organization feel like the models
should
should cover in order for them to be
developed and deployed in a responsible
manner
and now i will give the word to my
colleague leonard to tell you a little
bit more on how to get involved if you
are interested in that
indeed so the the technical and the
organizational best practices that are
presented to you they're really the core
of our work
um they are open source and they're
freely available online
and because the best practices are quite
detailed and comprehensive
it's quite a long document so we suggest
you start off by looking at the specific
issue
that you're concerned about we're also
working on different forms of supporting
material to make the best practices more
approachable
and
and to incorporate sort of context
specific information so for example
we're developing a guide at the moment
for how to use fairness metrics
depending on your application and the
type of organization you work in
moving on to the next slide
our best practices were designed first
and foremost for you people
for the data science and the machine
learning community
so we invite you all to use our best
practices and we would love to get your
feedback um as jolita mentioned our
foundation is relatively young and our
best practices are a work in progress so
your contributions will enable us to
further improve them
you can provide us with feedback via our
wiki whose link is over here
there's also a qr code to our wiki
and that is also where you will find the
supporting the supporting material to
our best practices
the link to our website is on the next
slide
if you would like to get involved we're
always on the lookout for volunteers um
we're a group of approximately 20 people
now and always happy to have new team
members who are also enthusiastic about
the topic of responsible ml and ai
ethics
um
so thank you very much for joining us
online today
and feel free to reach out to us on
linkedin or by email
yes there we go
um
thanks for that uh
uh
elon i'm i'm really hoping i pronounce
your name correctly if you could please
get set up uh you are the final speaker
of this round
so hi everyone um i'm going to
make an argument for less awesome
awesomeness today
um before jumping in just a couple of
words about myself i'm assuming that the
site is at spotify but of course what
i'm showing you today is not related to
my work with spotify i'm in the uk i'm
slasher or neil on most uh websites and
services
and uh please also check out my other
pilot global talk because i am a big
believer in upsetting and cross
promotion so if you enjoy if you will
enjoy this let me talk please uh
consider watching other talks
um
anyway so what are awesome so
from the kind of the awesomeness
manifesto an awesome list is
a list
of awesome things
curated by the community so you've
probably seen these uh on github there's
so many awesome ways for pretty much
anything there are currently over four
thousand
uh awesomeness on github and there is
even an awesome list of awesome lists uh
which is very meta and you know all
sorts of uh websites that offer like
search functionality form and
awesomeness and so on so it's a really
big deal over on
on github and
if i can give kind of an example from my
own point of view
um i'm interested one of the topics i'm
interested in is social network analysis
and if we go to the awesome list for
resources for
network analysis you can find this
really really great uh collection of
resources
but the problem is that it's huge so
um
you can see here the snapshot of you
know top to bottom all of the resources
on
that repo um and it's a lot it's more
than 900 external links
and and so
that's great that's awesome but it's
also a problem
because you have
900 or north of
900 really really high quality resources
it's not like you know um
simple things like 10 things data
scientists must know about network
analysis these are quality articles and
papers and videos and whatnot
that have been uh vetted by the
community and they're all high quality
and when you have so many high quality
resources at your finger
tips if you're anything like me then you
are going to develop a strong case of
fossum which is the fear of missing out
something awesome well in other words
you know i'm a millennial we want it all
and i want to know and there's just
absolutely no way
to consume everything that awesomeness
offer
so
uh i'm kind of trying to make the case
for an alternative that will sit
side by side with awesomeness
um so the vision is um to provide a
highly curated
human
human-friendly
digestible
list
of resources for anyone interested in a
certain field
so again in the theme of uh
cross-promotions
uh as i mentioned i'm super interested
in
network analysis and i gave a talk about
it in pi con
u.s a couple of months ago so
if you think about that we have a
small awesome awesomeness those next
size awesome list for resources around
network analysis recording snacks
because sna stands for social network
analysis
and you can see like uh hand by hand uh
step-by-step handhold will hand hold you
through the process of discovering what
network analysis is and
um getting making sure that you get the
intuition right and you know the
building blocks right and everything
like that
and secondly kind of more recently there
is another uh project around causal
inference which is also the talk i gave
earlier today so this is really really
early days we call it just cause because
that's the best thing that you could
come up with
but uh this is really early days we only
made it available publicly yesterday
because there was some demand for it but
there's not much there now so we would
really appreciate and anyone who wants
to chime in and contribute
um so just going back to snacks for a
second this is the whole screenshot
um
so
more manageable there's about 70
resources
uh we handhold you through the process
everything is kind of set up uh
homologically and you know we make sure
that we go at it you know step by step
and like we said those like like i just
said i'm sorry uh it's a work in
progress so the best is yet to come
which leads us to you know
my call to you please get involved be
awesome and contribute snacks or just
goes um you know ping me on select
twitter just open an issue or a pull
request and
we would appreciate any help we can get
uh with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and remind you to
be awesome to each other
thank you
okay
so thank you very much this was our
final lightning talk speaker uh but
there are a couple of poems that people
have sent to me that i would like to
dictate to you to send you along your
your day the weekend is nearly here for
most of us in europe but
roses are red my data is blue watch what
i can do with an eigenvalue
roses are red my data is blue i wrote
state-of-the-art code in a file called
untitled 32
roses are red i feel the burn i use the
deep learning tool but i should have
used so i could learn
i hope you all have a very lovely
evening and
enjoy the conference